Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at whether
or not it's actually possible to speed read.
Approximately 95% of college educated individuals
read at a rate between 200-400 words per minute
according to extensive research done by University
of Massachusetts Amherst professor Dr. Keith
Rayner.
However, there exists a small, but rather
vocal subset of people who insist that they
can read several times faster than this using
various speed reading techniques.
With very little searching, you’ll also
find many-a-company claiming that after going
through their program or using their app regularly,
you can easily read even as many as 1,000
words per minute.
Tim Ferriss of Four Hour Work Week fame offers
a method for increasing speed in reading for
free on his website, claiming with this method,
you’ll see an average increase in reading
speed of about 386% in just three hours of
practice.
So is any of this really possible?
When it comes to reading, comprehension is
everything.
Reading text twice as fast as someone else
isn’t often very helpful if, after you’re
done, you don’t understand or retain much
of what you read.
And this is where most speed reading programs
break down.
Studies have repeatedly shown that speed readers
almost universally score significantly worse
on reading comprehension tests than people
who consume the text at a more normal pace.
Perhaps the most famous test concerning this
was conducted by Dr. Ronald Carver, author
of The Causes of High and Low Reading Achievement.
Among many other studies he’s done over
the years looking at reading speed and comprehension,
in one notable one, he painstakingly sought
out the best speed readers he could find,
first choosing his subjects via testing a
large group of college students for their
speed reading and comprehension abilities
and then selecting the top scorers; next selecting
people whose jobs required exceptional amounts
of daily reading, such as a writer from the
New Yorker; and third selecting a few very
prominent individuals who’d built reputations
on their speed reading abilities.
What Carver was hoping to do here was collect
the best of the best among individuals who’d
previously demonstrated great aptitude for
speed reading while maintaining high levels
of reading comprehension.
He wanted to see if they really had abilities
much outside of a normal college educated
individual when tested in a scientifically
rigorous fashion.
It turns out, not one of these elite readers
could achieve a 75% reading comprehension
level (C average) while reading above 600
words per minute.
While this is decidedly faster than an average
college educated adult, it should be emphasized
again that Carver meticulously screened the
candidates in his study to find the best of
the best in terms of speed readers.
And the best from that group still could only
achieve about a C average in reading comprehension
at a maximum of 1/3 faster than what is generally
considered the normal ceiling of an average
college level reader.
To quote the aforementioned Professor Keith
Raynor, author of Eye Movements and Information
Processing During Reading: 20 Years of Research,
“Very few people can read faster than 400
words per minute, and any gain would likely
come with an unacceptable loss of comprehension.”
Dr. Raynor goes on to state,
"You can probably push yourself to get a little
over 500 words per minute, but you’re limited
by the eyes and the anatomy of the retina.
To understand text you need to move your eyes
to put the fovea (the part of your eye responsible
for sharp, central vision) on the part of
the text you want to focus.
Acuity drops off pretty markedly outside the
fovea and you can’t discriminate the words
and text far from the fovea.
So, that’s the rate limited factor, as is
how fast the brain can process information."
An indeed, many speed reading techniques try
to focus on cutting down on eye movements
that on average take about a tenth of a second
each movement or “saccade”.
These techniques claim you can reduce the
number of eye movements by doing things like
reading two lines at once or taking in as
many words as possible before an eye movement.
But, as Raynor notes,
"The other claim is that you can take in more
information per eye fixation, but there’s
no evidence that says we can do that.
What we know about the physiology of the retina
is against the notion that you can take in
two lines of text at the same time."
Another common speed reading method is to
try to eliminate subvocalization (saying words
in your head while reading).
Raynor notes that working towards this end
can help, but ultimately, “Research shows
that when you do that and the text is difficult,
comprehension goes to pieces.”
Essentially, your brain needs that time to
not just see the word, but understand its
meaning.
Take away that “pause” while you subvocalize
and while you might have looked at a lot of
words on a page, you’re not going to understand
or remember them later.
Everyone has experienced something like this
at one point or another where they read a
page, but are either thinking of something
else or spacing out.
You get to the end of the page and realize
you have no clue at all what you just read
even though your eyes looked at all the words.
Further, both Carver and Raynor found that
completely eliminating subvocalization while
reading just isn’t possible, even for skimmers.
This has been proven via hooking up electromagnetic
sensors to the throat.
It turns out, when you’re saying the words
in your head, your brain also is sending nerve
impulses to your speech controlling muscles,
whether you notice or not, which can be picked
up via these electromagnetic sensors.
Even the best of speed readers who claim to
have eliminated subvocalization have been
shown to have this happen.
Your eyes can only focus on so much at one
time and your brain also has processing limitations.
Once the words start getting streamed into
your brain too fast, your ability to comprehend
their meaning and retain anything from them
sharply declines.
So while speed reading apps that do things
like flash words at you on a single point
so you can get rid of the time it takes to
actually move your eyes to focus on a new
point can potentially speed up your reading
a bit, there is still the problem of how fast
your brain can actually process a word.
Apps that use this method tend to push the
upper limit and overload your brain’s ability
to comprehend, while also not letting you
glance back at any words your brain finds
tricky.
Needless to say, comprehension levels tend
to be extremely poor using this speed reading
method because of this.
As such, one real method for increasing your
abilities as a reader, not to astounding levels
claimed by many-a-speed reading course or
app, but at least getting to the upper part
of that 200-400 word per minute curve, is
to work on your recognition vocabulary- your
ability to see a word and comprehend its meaning.
You can achieve this by simply reading a lot
and working at increasing your vocabulary.
The increase in reading speed by broadening
your recognition vocabulary can even be measured
directly via monitoring the aforementioned
nerve impulses to the muscles in your throat
and tongue while you silently read.
It has been found that when you encounter
a word you’re not very familiar with, you
subvocalize it much slower than words your
brain recognizes more readily.
The other advantage to a larger recognition
vocabulary is reducing the number of times
your eyes have to jump back to re-read a word
or sentence, something that happens a lot
when your brain encounters difficult or unfamiliar
words, whether you consciously register you're
doing it or not.
This might all have you wondering if there
are any legitimate speed readers (as opposed
to advanced skimmers) out there?
The answer to that is Yes.
Michael Jordans of the reading world exist.
But unfortunately for us mere mortals, their
methods can’t be taught.
For instance, Kim Peek, a so-called megasavant
or “human Google”, who served as the inspiration
for Rain Man, was one such well known example.
While Peek’s mental prowess has been subjected
to significant embellishment over the years,
it is quite well documented that he could
seemingly effortlessly absorb all of the information
on a given page with remarkable speed.
While exactly how many words per minute he
could read with almost perfect comprehension
was never tested (at least that I could find
reliable documentation of), according to his
father who by necessity had to be his “shadow”
as Kim Peek called him, Kim generally averaged
about ten seconds a page and then could recall
it with almost perfect accuracy, even years
later.
This was an ability Kim was more than happy
to demonstrate, including in front of over
two and a half million people over the years
in various lecture halls and libraries across
the United States.
Once he came out of his shell a bit after
Rain Man, he’d even often walk up to strangers
on the street to demonstrate his astounding
memory and date-processing abilities.
This was one of the few ways he knew how to
socially interact with others.
However, Peek’s abilities were believed
to be the side effect of a serious congenital
birth defect known as agenesis of the corpus
callosum, in which the largest band of white
matter that connects the two hemispheres of
the brain doesn’t develop correctly; in
his case, it didn’t develop at all and his
brain compensated by making some rather unusual
connections, leaving him mentally and physically
handicapped in many ways, while also giving
him his truly remarkable memory.
So in the end, if you count what most think
of as skimming as “speed reading”, it
is absolutely possible to speed read, and
there certainly are techniques that can help
there.
For instance, a common, very simple one is
to only read the first sentence of each paragraph
in a book.
You’ll get the general idea of the chapter
without needing to read all the nitty-gritty
details.
But if you’re signing up to a course or
downloading an app that claims it will teach
you to read 1,000 words per minute with the
same reading comprehension levels as when
you read at your normal pace, you’re going
to be sorely disappointed at the actual results.
Universally, these courses are either selling
snake-oil or are going to teach you advanced
skimming skills- learning to quickly recognize
what to ignore and what to pay attention to
in text on the fly.
Being good at skimming can be an extremely
valuable skill in some circumstances, but
don’t expect to get anywhere close to the
level of reading comprehension you get when
reading at your normal pace.
After a certain point, the faster you go,
the less you’ll understand or remember later.
Bonus Fact:
While audiobooks, podcasts, and YouTube videos
can be very enjoyable to listen to, it turns
out it’s a slow way of getting information
compared to reading.
Even the fastest of speakers can typically
only get up to about 250-300 words per minute,
which on the latter end sounds a bit like
“auctioneer” talk.
And in fact it turns out, most people’s
brains are capable of comprehending speech
as high as about 300 words per minute, or
about the same as we can comfortably read
at.
For reference, a typical audiobook reader
will read at around 150-175 words per minute,
Simon's videos on this channel tend to ring
in around 175-190 words per minute and my
tend to be spoken at about 185-200 words per
minute.